[Music]
here in this video we will dive deep
into the symbiote celestial rivalry
their war and the powers between these
two factions as well as addressing the
big question did null and symbiotes
really kill and subjugate all the
celestials and how did they do that by
the end of the king and black storyline
these powerful space gods of the marvel
universe were near all-powerful and can
create stars and planets as well as
destroy them at will so how did they
fall against a bunch of amorphous
parasitic creatures
watch till the end of the video for a
conclusive answer so subscribe if you
haven't already and now let's get to it
let's start by talking a bit about the
origins of the celestials and the
symbiotes
both of them are very ancient entities
the celestials are older than all the
other symbiotes aside from null who has
been in existence even before the birth
of the current universe
celestials were created by the first
firmament which is the personified first
cosmos or the first universe
the celestials rebelled against their
creator and the aspirin counterparts in
a war that shattered the first universe
into the first multiverse the celestials
are involved in the creation of new
universes including that of the prime
marvel universe as of now they work with
the fulcrum now and are born from seeds
found within planet course
the symbiotes on the other hand are
inorganic amorphous symbiotic alien
species created by the primordial god
called null from the living abyss which
was there at the beginning of the cosmos
he created and projected a sort of
living darkness called the all-black the
necrosort from his shadow to murder the
celestials and the other gods across the
universe
it's impossible to say when null first
started making these amorphous parasites
from the living abyss but we do know
that he created the all-black first
which makes it the first proto-symbiote
and out of the head of the dead
celestial he made more of them an army
with him at the head of the hive mine
and went on to destroy civilizations
so the question begs why are the
symbiotes so against the celestials and
what are the origins of their rivalry
their war in the first place
well to start with uh the celestials
aren't actually good guys or even
villains really they are more or less
just indifferent to the lives of others
and are only concerned with the tasks
they are given for example arashim only
goes around judging the planets which
are experimented on tiamat only job is
to communicate the findings with the
fulcrum
jamia only analyzes the advancement of
the genetic experiments on different
planets across the universe
so let's just say that their actions are
often not thought out well enough and
such actions by them
brought about the wrath of null upon
them
so let's look at it from null's
perspective
imagine being a god of darkness and
having the time of his life enjoying
nothingness his own thoughts and dreams
and pin drop silence he might very well
be the ultimate introvert of the
universe
so there he is minding his own business
when all of a sudden his dark void that
he calls home is invaded by light from
everywhere it's a home invasion mind you
and the intruders are the celestials
breaking up things remaking everything
with light bulbs and led bulbs
these are stars and planets fyi i'm just
recreating a scenario so there he goes
back to his room and comes out with a
special sword called the all black and
starts hacking it on one of these
celestials decapitating its head but
then he was saddened or cast out by the
others because there are too many of
them so he retreats but swears to get
back his home one way or another
swearing vengeance on the home invaders
the celestials so that's how the war
started
so for us to know what the symbiotes
were really up against we have to know
what are the powers wielded by the
celestials and also the symbiotes the
celestials are immeasurable cosmic and
supernatural powers with seemingly no
limits many consider them to be the most
powerful energy generators in existence
they transcend the conventional
space-time structure and are considered
to be near-omnipotent entities the
celestials collectively shape the cosmos
in order to create life throughout the
universe
even though they can be killed they are
biologically immortal and only a select
few have enough strength to overpower
them or at least a single celestial at a
time
null has defeated a celestial in the
past but the only one we know of is the
seventh head of one which became the
mining colony called nowhere
so killing a celestial isn't really
impossible but it is pretty much near
impossible to many
galactus has defeated and killed one mad
celestial in one of his encounters but
was overpowered by the remaining three
that were also there as well
how null slayed celestials and gods in
the past is with the all-black the
necrosort which was made of the living
darkness the living abyss and channeled
the energy of the void something that
the celestials were surprisingly
vulnerable to but why
why were they vulnerable to this
well let's get into that now
so what are the real powers of the all
black and null
well he appears to have the same powers
that the all black the necrosod bestows
on its hose but to a higher level as he
is the creator
sounds a bit similar to how the ring of
power in the lord of the rings gives
some people
abilities but the real power is wielded
by sauron
so yeah much of nulls and all black's
power stems from the metaphysical
connection to the celestial's undead
body
which gives him power through the neck
resort in exchange for assimilation of
the souls that he kills
he also has control over the living
abyss the dark energy and even time to
an extent but the all black is the key
to it all it was made to nullify
immortal beings and inflict mortal
wounds on them and with each god of
celestial and slaves it grows stronger
feeding off of their powers when they
die
so by the time the king and black
storyline started the all black would
have been wielded by null the first one
then the infamous gore the god butcher
who killed thousands of gods with the
necrosod hell it was even wielded by
galactus and ego at some point so by now
the powers of the all black would have
far outgrew the resistance of the
celestials to it even if the first one
that was killed billions of years ago
was just a fluke
by now it would be able to put a
multitude of them down if it bonds with
the right hose which was null in the end
the original hose its creator
and with null at the head again of the
symbiote hive mind he was able to kill
and overpower maybe all the remaining
celestials
okay now we come to the scene where the
celestials descended into the earth and
they were clad in a symbiote outgrowth
kind of like an armor now the question
comes to mind did the symbiotes really
bond with the defeated celestials or
were they only reanimated bodies
the first instinct is to say that these
were forcefully bonded with weakened
celestials therefore enslaving them to
the hive mine but this would be far too
difficult or even impossible as it
wasn't the all black itself but separate
symbiotes that infected these celestials
may be a breed of these that were
perfected by null into parasites that
are able to reanimate gigantic dead
mechanical bodies
but they still won't be powerful enough
to override or mentally overpower a
celestial
so even though a symbiote could bond
with a celestial if it tried to
it would definitely be destroyed by the
host in an instant from either the sound
one could generate or the immense heat
that these cosmic generators can create
and yes we even see iron man converting
one of the symbiote celestials into his
own suit of armor using the extremity
this didn't allow the celestial to
become free because it wasn't alive
anymore so the only answer is that the
enslaved celestials were in fact dead
ones and the symbiotes only resurrected
them by bonding with the residual life
force that the celestials usually have
because celestials have this
characteristic they can be revived by
one of their own kind if the need arises
they can die but they do have this
residual life force that can be
researched within them if the time comes
so yeah that's that
anyway now we know the origins of the
celestials the symbiotes the origin of
their rivalry their war
how null can kill one of them and how
powerfully all black is and most
importantly that these celestials that
were enslaved were in fact dead ones and
not alive
so that's that now we have come to the
end of the video
so do hit the like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam